well
[Música]
could life such and such and jaramillo with
his brief news of the day today several
animal advocates will demand charges
for the owners of a dog that died in
the bucks of Vigués their pet was
tied up in the immovable patio
a neighbor detected this  incident and
recorded this argument that the animal was
barking in anguish while it was
outside in the extreme heat for several
days north las vegas police
are investigating what happened but
so far no arrests have been made
a group will march today at
las city hall  vegas to ask for justice
today county commissioners who will give
an update related to the
fight against the coronavirus the county
obtained high figures in terms of
positive cases and deaths during mid-
June and July, however there has been a
decrease in people hospitalized by the
virus for approximately seven
consecutive weeks
the students of the cis and now they will be able to
register to  a new program this would
allow them to run
distance learning under supervision and in a
safe environment is Monday through Friday from
7 a.m. to 6
p.m. students who qualify for
free or reduced lunch can
sign up for free for more
information visit disney.com and now
we go to the weather forecast today
we are back to temperatures
rolling 100 degrees however we will have
hotter days heading into the
weekend have a nice day i
am sal ethan dude and this was
[Music]